welcome to the man of recaps this is
house of the dragon episode four this
episode focuses on who princess rhaenyra
is going to marry she's out on a tour
right now talking to a bunch of suitors
most of whom are not suitable there's a
funny noteworthy scene when this 12 year
old puts his name out there and he's
being sassed by some dude on the
sidelines if you know your deep game of
thrones lore this is houses blackwood
and bracken who have a huge family feud
soon it turns into a duel but it's
actually kind of funny when they look
back and the 12 year old won but nowhere
near is done with this she's going home
but what's this on the boat back
something's coming oh a dragon flyby yes
it's her uncle damon pulling the
maverick top gun buzz in the tower it's
been another year but now finally damon
targaryen is coming back to king's
landing with a sweet new haircut but
more noticeably he's wearing a crown
right now so it's a big tense moment as
everyone's like what's going on is he
gonna claim the throne but he's not here
to cause trouble he's like what's up bro
i killed the crab beater for you oh this
thing now my men just named me king of
the narrow sea but you know you're the
real king and so with damon returning a
hero and being humble he and his brother
hug it out and that's all forgiven so
things are good the targaryens are a
nice happy family again in fact rhaenyra
and her old best friend allison finally
make up rhaenyra now that she's being
forced to marry understands that allison
didn't really have a choice in the
matter and it's like okay sis let's be
best friends again then we're near and
damon have a nice chat about marriage
remember he is married to some woman in
the veil but he hasn't seen her in ages
he really doesn't like her and he's like
look niece you know you have to get
married to someone but then you just do
whatever you want she's like yeah that
might work for men but for me it's not
gonna be like that i'll be sort of a
prisoner in my new husband's castle just
forced to pump out airs and that's not
the light she wants that night she finds
in her room a bunch of street clothes
and a note that shows her where the
hidden secret passage is so she dresses
like a commoner and sneaks out of the
castle and it's her uncle damon like
what's up niece let me show you a good
time there's a party in king's landing
tonight it's an awesome time they have a
lot of fun until they go see a play
about the targaryen line of succession
and it doesn't paint ranira in a
flattering light but the party continues
damon takes her to the next bar which is
less of a bar and more of a brothel uh
uncle where are you taking me oh yeah it
wouldn't be game of thrones without a
little bit of incest now they're
targaryens the house of the dragon whose
ancestors married brother and sister so
it's not that taboo and they have kind
of a sexy scene here yeah they're both
into it but they don't get very far
damon pulls away because even though
targaryen incest isn't that taboo maybe
he still feels it would be inappropriate
to bang his young niece so after this
raniera goes home walking past her
bodyguard sir kristen cole who's like
wait how'd she get out and in fact she's
feeling feisty from her big night out
her uncle's speech about taking what you
want has gotten to her and she's like
hey boy let's do it he's like yo we
really shouldn't but she really wants to
and so finally he caves and so it's a
hilariously long scene as she takes off
all the armor he's wearing it's
exhausting but then rhaenyra and sir
kristen cole who have had good chemistry
since the beginning get it on
so yeah if you were thinking the show's
had a lack of sex so far compared to
game of thrones they're like here's a
whole episode of it for you but some
kids spotted ranira coming out of the
brothel with damon and he reports to the
hand otto hightower so in the morning
it's like hey king got some bad news uh
your daughter and your brother were
getting it on damon said we're
targaryans we can do whatever we want
but that's not really the case the rest
of the realm would still find this
wildly inappropriate especially because
westeros has that outdated unfair
bridgerton moral system where a woman
having sex before marriage spoils her
it's alison who goes to confront rania
about this like yo did you bang your
uncle ranira denies she's like yeah we
went into a brothel together but not
together he was there doing his own
thing and i left shortly after rhaenyra
swears she and damon did not have sex
which is true but it leaves out the fact
that they almost did and that she bangs
her kristen later as for damon he did
stay out late partying and has kind of a
nasty hangover made worse because he's
thrown on the floor of the iron throne
viserys is real mad at his brother but
damon doesn't confirm or deny the rumors
he's like what if i did it wouldn't be
that bad she's an adult it was fully
consensual and we're the house of the
dragon we should be able to do whatever
we want he's like look if no other lord
will marry her now because she's
despoiled marry her to me it's the old
targaryen custom and conveniently clears
up this whole who should be the air
thing and now viserys is suspicious that
was damon's plan all along to seduce
rhaenyra so she'd have to marry him and
he would still get to be king he's like
bro we were friends again for one day
but now i'm more mad than ever i never
want to see you again so it's finally
time for a direct father-daughter chat
about this and viserys is pretty mad
rainier is like hey dad aren't you even
going to ask me if it's true but he
points out an important fact it doesn't
matter if it's true perception is all
that matters if this gets out everyone
will believe it he's like look we gotta
end this you're gonna marry right now
and i'm picking for you it'll be leonard
valerian rainier is like fine i'll do it
but you gotta think about where this
news came from your loyal hand otto
hightower was spying on me bringing this
news to you to make you maybe disinherit
me he wants his grandson aegon to be
king so he's not giving you unbiased
advice anymore so becerras calls auto in
for an employee evaluation like you know
i didn't realize it at the time but it
was weirdly convenient for you that your
hot daughter showed up to comfort me
when my wife died i'm starting to think
you orchestrated that you've been a good
hand of the king all these years but now
i think you're putting your ambition
above the realm so you fired how will
otto hightower take this will he go
quietly into retirement we'll find out
in the final scene the grand maester
brings rhaenyra a nice cup of tea a tea
that gets rid of unwanted pregnancies
just in case now this is convenient
because she did sleep with sir kristin
cole although no one knows that if she
drinks it everyone might think that she
and damon did sleep together but we'll
see so damon targaryen is banished again
renera is going to marry lenar valerian
and otto hightower is no longer hand to
the king all these things are heating up
they might boil over soon and that's
where episode 4 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]